the last days of ptolemy grey's story of
a man who lives in delusions
i'm so sorry he's in his mid 90s he's
right there at the press of his full-out
dementia
he's far in the back of his own mind he
needs help seemed like i can't remember
nothing no more
they go to a doctor who has this miracle
drug after the doses are administered mr
gray will remember everything that he
has ever known the doctor has a medicine
that will bring him back to
consciousness for maybe a month this is
an opportunity to reclaim parts of his
life that he's been searching for
[Music]
[Applause]
he takes the medicine he regains his
memory
in a very slender window of time he
tries to do all the things in his life
that he failed at
he wants to
fix his relationships and solve a riddle
in his mind
and it drives the story
what is he trying to do and why does he
need to do it so badly
come on in
cincy
she gone boy
this is a man struggling to reclaim his
life through his memories
we have our present-day story we have
flashbacks to 1930s mississippi and we
have 70 sequences and it was really
really amazing to see
all of these things come to life
it's almost time
let's begin home
me and walter been trying to do this
project for like 10 years it's a
universal thing
when
you have a loved one that doesn't know
who you are anymore it's like the most
heartbreaking thing
in the world
sam has gone to a place that he hasn't
usually gone
sam is so perfect for this role because
it needs an actor of a certain maturity
and a certain genius
what's going to be really compelling for
his fans and for the audience is to see
him in a role where he is
vulnerable much older very different
from
anything we've ever seen him do
it's a fanciful story of
what someone would do if they had an
opportunity to right the wrongs of a
life that they live
we carry such shame for the things that
we've done in our past and at the end of
the day you got one life to live so what
are we going to do with it while we're
here
there are times when you get it right
we had the time
and the space
to get this right
[Music]
you